please welcome Matthew dicks to the
stage thank
you I'm standing on the playground
behind my school it's recess Duty when
my son was very little he asked me is
recess Duty like Duty like poop and I
said yeah actually it is just like that
and I sent him away I I'm sure that
conversation created enormous problems
for him at some point in his life but it
was an accurate description of recess
Duty I waste my precious time putting
Band-Aids on cuts that are not Cuts
pretending to listen to stories about
cousins birthday parties and telling
mean children that they have no one to
play with because they are
mean and so I'm standing there doing all
of these things when I hear these four
words that strike fear into my heart
never have I ever and I look over and I
see three of my students 10-year-old
girls on the sidewalk and apparently
they are playing this game so now I am
running cuz I have played never have I
ever I understand the Dynamics of this
game this is not a benevolent game where
we acquire knowledge about our friends
this is social combat this is we extract
information from foolish children and
then we sharpen it and we stab them with
it later on so I'm running over like 198
85 Jimbo Po's birthday party Melissa
says Matt never have you ever kissed
someone and immediately I have to figure
out do I tell the truth basically what
I'm wondering is is everyone else in
this room kiss somebody because if so
now I have to lie and say yes and I have
to prepare myself for the questions that
will come which will undoubtedly be who
did you kiss and since no one has ever
kissed me in my school and probably
never will I have to make up a story
about the time my parents took me to the
farflung land of Pucket Rhode Island or
wooer and I was in a candy store and I
had to trist by a licorice stand with a
girl story that did not work a kid once
asked me never have you ever gone to
third base and I knew it wasn't about
baseball but that is all I knew about
that question so I am running to these
girls and as I get close I hear one of
them say never have I ever gone to bed
without brushing my
teeth and I sort of grind to a hall
because this this is not 1985 sex and
drugs never have I ever this is like Paw
Patrol never have I ever it's fine it's
nothing wrong here and as I turn to walk
away the girls say Mr dicks you want to
play Never Have I Ever and they explain
to me that their game's a competition
they stand on the sidewalk and if you've
never ever done something you take a
step forward and whoever gets to the
bench first wins and now I'm all in
because I love competition I love to
crush small children in games that are
utterly meaningless so I can feel better
about myself as a human being so I'm
standing there on the line with the
girls and the first girl says never have
I ever climbed a mountain and all three
of them step forward I'm like are you
kidding me you're 10 and you've never
gone up a mountain like no lie when I'm
12 I get lost in the White Mountains of
New Hampshire for two days and nobody
cares including me they've never climbed
a mountain before the next girl says
never have I ever gone to bed without a
nightlight on and I think oh my God lady
don't say that cuz we're all going to
make fun of you for it and then I
realize oh my God I'm the only one who's
going to make fun of her for of this
like this group of children that I'm
taking care of they're so different than
I was like they've taken all their
daggers and put them away they're sweet
they're accepting it's not all good no
no it's not all good like they this
generation of children can't get 10t
from a water bottle without being
triggered in some way they're the most
hydrated group of kids I've ever met in
my entire ire life it is a nightmare
they can't go through my math lessons
without a squishy thing or a stuffed
animal I had a girl last week in my math
lesson with a blanket wrapped around her
I said what's up with the blanket she
said it makes me happy during math I
said math isn't happy it's awful it's
hard it's honorous I would have loved to
have a water bottle and a and a blanket
and a stuffed animal during math when I
was a kid all I had was angst and
despair it made me who I am
I can't stand these kids and I'm losing
the game because I have done everything
and they've done nothing so they're nine
steps ahead of
me and then the tallest girl says never
have I ever met my father's
expectations and I think that is
nonsense cuz I know your fathers they're
all fine men what are you talking about
and one of the girls says well I'm a
swimmer and when I get a PR in the pool
and I come out my dad's happy for me but
then he says but just imagine how much
better you could have been if you had
nailed the kick turn on the third lap
and the next girl says well I mastered
my multiplication facts last month and
when I came home to my dad he said
that's great but why didn't you do it in
October when you were supposed to and
the third one says my dad always tells
me how I can be better and I know he
does it because he loves me but it never
feels like love and now I'm panicking
I'm thinking what about my children
Charlie and Clara have I ever told them
that they've met my expectations they
never have I mean they don't even come
close like but hi have I at least fooled
them into believing that they
occasionally meet my
expectations and so as I'm panicking
about this situation the tall girl says
Mr dicks have you ever met your father's
expectations and I catch for a minute I
don't know what to say but then I know
exactly what to say because I've been
working with kids for 25 years as a
teacher and I know they're they're more
capable than we all know and so I tell
her I say my father left when I was
seven and he never came back and so I
don't think he ever had expectations for
me and three hands reach out and they
grab my wrist and they pull me forward
and that girl says that counts Mr
dicks and then she tells
me I'm sorry your father abandoned you
when you were a kid and it is crazy
but from the age of 7 to
52 I have basically been waiting for my
father to come back and it is not until
I'm on a sidewalk with a 10-year-old
girl that I understand for the first
time that he is not coming back it is
the first time I have ever in my life
heard the word abandoned used to
describe
what happened to me and it is the first
time ever that a human being has ever
said to me I'm sorry that happened to
you my friends have said that sucked it
was terrible I know that my wife hates
what happened to me as a
boy but that 10-year-old girl she was
the first person to tell me I am sorry
for what happened to you when you are
7 when people ask me today why I am
still a public school teacher after 25
years with all of the Unspeakable
ridiculous nonsensical
impossible things that school teachers
go through today and with quite honestly
all the other opportunities I have to
leave a classroom and go do other things
with my life my answer is always
immediate and
simple I love kids but far more
important than
that kids understand
me and they speak truth to me and they
love me thank
you Matthew dicks